new Turkey relations are at breaking
point anchor as response to an attempted
coup in July mass arrests including of
journalists and opposition politicians
the blanket dismissal of public servants
has shocked many in Europe MEP is now
called for a temporary freeze of turkeys
EU membership talks instead of
continuing the illusion of accession
talks with with the regime that becomes
more and more authoritarian I think that
we are losing credibility to do so the
talks began in 2005 and have been used
main diplomatic lever for reform there
the --use foreign affairs chief says
Europe still needs turkey on sight given
the migration crisis terrorism and
Cyprus reunification talks if the
accession process came to an end I
believe we would both find ourselves in
a lose-lose scenario but the parliaments
Rapporteur on Turkey is still keeping
the door open I very much hope that this
is a temporary thing but the key lies in
the hands of the government in Turkey in
order for these talks to be unfrozen